Is there a specific tumor marker for a suffered geolcancer?
If yes, what would be the range of numbers?
We spoke to our internist about laser surgery for the esophagus.
He said, it would not get rid of the cancer,
but would improve the esophagus for eating solids.
We did not know of any laser surgeons for that part of the body.
Do you know of any specific laser surgeons?
So I don't know of any specific laser surgeons.
We might have to continue to seek some advice from medical professions for that.
There is no specific tumor marker for a suffered geolcancer.
You could run a tumor marker panel and any of them might show up,
but there's none that are specific for that cancer.